For experts in emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with Dr. David
Watson on personality and emotion.
Dr. Watson is the Andrew Mckenna
family professor of psychology at the
University of Notre Dame,
Dr. Watson as a personality psychologist
with particular expertise in
personality assessment.
His work investigates the structure
and measurement of personality,
mood and psychopathology as well as
examining how personality traits relate to
clinical disorders.
He works in a variety of substantive
areas within psychopathology,
including depression and the anxiety
disorders, personality disorders, skizzy,
tippy,
and the sleep and associated disorders.
The longterm goal of his work
is to develop comprehensive
taxonomic models that
integrate normal range and pathological
processes into a single overarching
scheme. Dr. Watson has published more
than 100 articles in the top journals in
psychology, including the Journal of
personality and Social Psychology,
the journal of abnormal psychology,
psychological bulletin and psychological
assessment and he's currently serves as
editor and chief of the
Journal of abnormal psychology.
So I now turn to a very special experts
and emotion interview with Dr. David
Watson on personality and emotion.
So I want to thank you for
speaking with us today. David,
welcome.
Thanks for having me.
Fantastic.
So one of the questions I wanted to start
a asking you was really where this all
began for you. So what first sparked
your interest in, got you. You know,
started in studying processes of emotion.
Oh, well, I don't know if my
answer is typical or atypical, uh,
but it's was completely
serendipitous. So, uh,
the backstory is my future wife got a
Fulbright fellowship to study in Japan,
uh, and I wanted to go with her.
So I was talking to Alcatel Hogan,
who was my graduate advisor,
uh, and he said, well,
if you're going into the Japan, why
don't you do a mood study over in Japan?
And I said, okay. That became
my dissertation. So, uh,
as part of this, I started
reading up on the mood literature,
which was actually pretty small
back then. And I really, you know,
I fell in love with it,
but I can't say before that I
had the slightest interest in it.
Hmm.
I never would have
anticipated going into it.
So it's one of those serendipitous
discoveries into the world of emotion.
Yeah. And, and you know, the world
was very different back then. Uh,
there was not much of an
emotional literature. Uh,
the mood literature was quite small. I
really mastered it, I would say in a week.
Hmm.
Um, it was, it was not, it was not the
golden age of emotion research back then.
Do you know what sort of
kept your attention going in,
in the world of emotion and
mood once you got hooked?
Well, the thing I liked about it
was that it was so pliable. I mean,
you could, uh, you know, you could study
biological processes, you could study,
like facial expressions,
could study situational factors.
So in some of our early work, we
looked at exercise, social activity,
caffeine, uh, weather variables. Uh,
it had obvious connections
to psychopathology. And
then, you know, finally,
of course it was related to personality.
So, you know, I think it was, uh,
it was really an expansive topic.
What did,
which you could take in a lot of
different directions rather than being
restrictive. And you know, back then it
seemed like it was completely wide open.
I mean you, you know, there was so
little research that was done, uh,
than almost anything you
did, uh, was innovative.
Hmm. That's so interesting. So I mean,
since then you've done just a wide number
of innovative things and actually had
trouble finding just,
you know,
one small cluster of questions I could
ask you about because there's just so
many things on, could talk
with you about. Um, the,
one of the things I thought I might start
by asking you about is just about your
work. Um, so you're widely known for your
influential work on the development and
assessment of personality.
And I wondered how you think research
on aspect and emotion can improve our
understanding of variation
in personality traits?
Well, I think in a, in a couple of
ways. So first of all, what, uh,
when people started doing research
on an affect and emotion, uh,
I think the conventional wisdom was that
most personality did not have much to
do with emotion.
I think going back to Isaac,
most people thought that neuroticism
was about negative emotion. Uh,
but if you read about traits such as
conscientiousness and extraversion,
um,
the,
the focus was on cognitive behavioral
processes, social processes,
not emotional processes.
So I think the emotion research is
fundamentally changed the way that we've,
we view these traits, I
think. But in terms of, uh,
the major traits or personality,
maybe something like intellect or
openness doesn't have a strong emotional
component, but pretty much everything else
does. Uh, and so I, and I think this is,
this has really changed the way
that we view personality traits. Uh,
when I started in the field in the 1970s,
the field was primarily
descriptive. Um, and now, uh,
I think linking personality too,
emotional research has also clarified
the biological bases for these things.
I mean, you know, uh, inhibition system,
the approach system and how they're
related to traits like neuroticism,
extraversion.
Uh,
I think the next generation of research
is going to be to try to understand, uh,
their particular emotional signatures
of different traits. So, uh,
I think one of the challenges we're
working on in my lab right now, uh,
is conscientiousness as a personality
trait has surprisingly strong connections
to depression and the anxiety disorders.
And I suspect a lot of that again,
is emotionally based,
but we really don't understand
that very well right now. Hmm. Mm.
How do
you think we might use some of this
information to better inform our clinical
assessment of personality disorders?
Well, personality disorders, uh, I think
offers some interesting challenges,
um, particularly, uh, in the
assessment of positive emotion.
I think because,
uh,
you have disorders such as
avoidant personality disorder,
a borderline that seemed to be
associated with deficits in positive
emotionality, but then there's
good evidence that, uh,
there are the disorders such as
narcissistic personality disorder,
Histrionic personality disorder that are
associated with elevated positive mode.
And in fact, when you
start looking at, uh, uh,
specific aspects of personality
disorders, um, many, uh,
aspects of the related to
positive emotionality and
extroversion actually can go
both ways.
So you have people who are dependent,
overly dependent on
others, uh, who, uh, are,
are, have, are more,
almost clingy and dependent
on other people, uh,
that are afraid of being abandoned.
And then you have people
who are extremely aloof, um,
and our colon and
different to other people.
So I think that dimension in
particular has a lot of potential for
differentiating different types of
clinical conditions and you know,
and try to figure out, you know, why,
why we see such wide ranges in behavior.
Yeah,
that's fascinating.
I mean,
one of the other things about your work
that I found particularly exciting is
that you've also scientifically
demonstrated how we can
use measures of positive
and negative effect to
differentiate among, you know,
anxiety and mood disorders,
um,
in ways that we just didn't
understand previously.
And I wondered if you could just say a
bit more about what you found to be some
of the most important or
exciting discoveries here.
Well, probably our first major
discovery was in the area of depression,
uh, which, which seems to be,
we've now looked at a
wide range of disorders,
not everything but a
wide range of disorders.
And depression seems to be associated
with a particularly strong deficits in
positive emotionality.
And an extreme case is it seems to be a,
an inability to experience normal
levels of positive emotion,
uh, and just really
differentiates, uh, depression, uh,
from some other disorders,
even a disorders such as
generalized anxiety disorder,
which is strongly Comorbid with
it and strongly related to it. Uh,
and I think one of the things that's
striking from some of our recent symptom
work is that a positive
emotionality is actually a better,
more specific symptom of depression,
even though it's not part of the
formal symptom criteria for depression.
Then many of the current depression
symptoms are, so for example,
insomnia tends to be a
more nonspecific symptom,
which is pervasive in
clinical populations. Uh,
so it's an interesting system as symptom,
but it doesn't really differentiate a
depression from other consortia. So I,
you know, I've been writing
about this in recent years.
I think the implication is that we need
to be building a positive emotionality
criteria into more clinical syndromes.
I think that we're really would
improve diagnosis and assessment.
And I wanted to ask you a bit about that.
So in what ways do you think we
can leverage this information,
especially related to positive effect
as you just pointed out in the case of
depression? Um, to aid in, you know,
differential diagnosis or developing and
refining treatment interventions that
are really focused on these, you
know, aspect related symptoms?
Yeah, well, you know,
having studied a diagnosis and
assessment for a number of years in,
in some ways it's impressive,
but I,
I think that a clinical
assessment is biased yeah. Uh,
toward,
uh,
an assessment terms towards convergent
validity or if you prefer to posit toward
positive symptoms. So I think, uh,
clinicians have been very
adept at identifying problems
that patients complain
about. Um, you know, so they can't sleep,
they're having trouble
eating, they're unhappy. Uh,
but I think they've
underrepresented deficits,
so things that should be there
but aren't, and quite often, uh,
positives about positive emotional
symptoms, symptoms are related to that.
So when we don't,
we don't see normal levels of happiness,
we don't see normal levels of engagement.
Those types of symptoms seem to be
underrepresented. Uh, and I think that,
uh,
clinicians in diagnostic criteria tend
to under represent a more specific
symptoms. So I quite
often they overweight, uh,
problems and symptoms that are common
to all kinds of conditions. Um,
and so again,
I think that's why the positive system
is particularly interesting because you
see the large deficits in some disorders,
a few deficits in many disorders,
and then you see elevations in positive
and so like excessive approach behavior,
overconfidence, uh, in other conditions.
Well this relates to the last question
I wanted to ask you about your work. Um,
so as you're saying,
a lot of your recent work has focused on
the assessment of positive emotionality
using the eye das to scale and how it
relates both to personality on the one
hand and psychopathology.
On the other hand,
and I wonder if you could tell us a bit
more about the specificity of positive
emotion dysfunction that you've
been showing in your work,
especially since this is
really a relatively new
field to begin to sort of on
earth in the realm of
both, you know, emotion,
just studying positive emotion more
generally and applying it clinically.
We know almost nothing about positive
emotion and how it tells us about unique
features of different
psychological disorders.
Yeah. So then that's another
serendipitous finding. I,
I kind of got dragged into the assessment
of a excessive positive emotionality,
particularly in the context of a
bipolar symptoms of bipolar disorder.
Uh, it does, I wouldn't,
I would not say it's completely
specific to bipolar disorder.
They seem to be a similar elevations
in narcissism, for example.
Uh, but the specificity is,
is really remarkable. Um,
we're still struggling to understand
that because in some cases we have
measures, we've developed symptom
measures that seem to be similar. Uh,
empirically they're correlated
with each other. Uh,
and yet one measure shows deficits and
depression and other one shows elevations
in mania. So what exactly
differentiates the two from each other?
Uh, you know, we, we've developed some
hypotheses. We're getting some data.
It seems that, uh, in, uh,
disorders that are associated
with elevated positive
mood seem to be associated
with excessive activation,
uh,
with overconfidence that leads
to impulsivity and recklessness.
Um,
but I think we have a long way to go to
figure out exactly what differentiates
that, you know, from more normal
adaptive forms of positive aspect.
And that's what I was going to ask you.
Do you think there's any glimmers of
ways in which we can use this scale?
The I'd to, to try to
tease apart, you know,
more maladaptive from adaptive
variations of normal, positive mood?
Are there ways that we can look forward
to try to make those rarely difficult
distinctions?
Uh, yeah. I, I think, uh, right now worse,
we're stymied to some extent by
limitations in our thinking and in our
assessment approach.
So again, we, you know,
we didn't necessarily
expect these things. So, uh,
one of the things we're trying to
do now is just to understand, um,
the specific type of positive
mood that's, that's, uh,
elevated in, um, for example,
bipolar disorder in general,
one of the problems that you face in
studying positive mood is going back to
Darwin.
They're well developed classification
systems for negative mood. I mean,
if you were to ask emotion theorists,
everyone would recognize anger.
They would recognize fear and
they wouldn't recognize discussed.
But when you get into positive emotions,
we don't really have a good taxonomy,
a good classification system. Uh,
people talk about amusement, joy,
interest, curiosity,
energy, vigor. I mean, um,
what are the basic positive
emotional states and how
they differ from each other.
I think that's going to be part of the
next generation is to figure out what's
going on there.
So thinking ahead then
about the next generation,
where do you see the future of emotion,
emotion research headed at this point?
Well, speaking for myself, I,
I think what we're seeing and,
and uh, I think this is going
to be the wave of the future,
uh,
is just complete integration.
So I'm asked to write a number of,
you know,
chapters and papers on
personality and emotion,
personality and psychopathology.
Uh,
but I think we're reaching the point
where you can't do this x and y kind of
thing, that they're all part of
the same systems. So what one week?
When I think of psychopathology,
I think primarily in terms of emotional
dysfunction, that's not all of it,
but that's a lot of it.
When I think of personality,
I think the variations and
emotional processes, when I study,
affect and emotion, there's obviously
very strong dispositional component to it.
Um, and I, you know,
integrating these things,
particularly in a biological context,
uh,
is going to be a crucial, uh, funding.
Now through an Imh, uh,
there are doc, um, system.
I think it's an explicit recognition of
this. Uh, so they're, you know, uh, and,
and Imh is moving away from a DSM
diagnostic categories and more in terms of
these underlying bio
emotional behavioral systems.
So I think integration,
full integration is the next step.
And a lot of the next step of course
involves not just current researchers in
the field, but also students who are
training to become the next generation.
And so when students your own or
others come to you and ask for advice,
sort of where, where should they
be putting their time and energy,
or what should they be focusing on?
What kind of advice do you have for
students just embarking in the study of
emotion?
No, I'm not sure. I'm very
good at giving advice. Um,
my advice is to, uh, is to,
is to find whatever is interesting to you,
uh,
and pursue that. Uh, I think my,
my career is somewhat different from many
of my contemporaries and that I really
resisted doing one type of thing.
Um,
I started out primarily as a mood
researcher. I did some clinical research.
I did some personality research,
uh, within the clinical world.
I studied probably a wider range of
disorders and just about anybody.
Um, but I, I follow, you know,
I just try to solve problems,
uh, that interest may,
and, uh, one of the,
I've gotten a lot of mileage
out of revisiting, uh,
areas and issues and realizing that I
was stymied at some point that I couldn't
figure out an answer to something and
that motivates me to continue on it.
And, um, I, at times I resist this. I say,
I can't solve this problem,
but eventually I go back to it.
And why can't I solve this problem? You
know, why are things the way they are?
That's about all the advice I can give.
That's really good advice.
Thank you so much for the advice and
thank you so much for speaking with us
today. David. Thanks again for having,
this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Dr. David Watson.